three major stories all involving a
former Trump aide named Sam Nunn bird
breaking in the last 24 hours Sam Nunn
bird number one has been subpoenaed to
testify and Robert molars Trump Russia
investigation and that is part of Story
number one which is he is refusing to
testify saying he will ignore the
subpoena number two story about Sam Nunn
Berg is that he admitted during an
interview on CNN with Jake Tapper that
Carter page was colluding with the
Russians and number three Sam Nunn Berg
believes that Muller has something
specifically on Donald Trump let's at
least attempt to break this down into
its component parts and we'll start with
the subpoena Sam Nunn Berg met with
Robert molars investigators a couple of
weeks ago he has been subpoenaed and he
says he will reject the subpoena he says
come and arrest me and that is maybe
what will actually happen that is part
one part two is that he admitted on CNN
to Jake Tapper that he believes Carter
page flat-out colluded with the Russians
here he is yesterday during one of his
many many many weird interviews about
communications or Carter page do you
think I became you became a cargo page
I'm going to the scumbag okay so the
answer is no he would not communicate
with Carter
so the answer's no and Carter page was
colluding with the Russians so Carter
page was colluding with the residents
you think yeah I believe Carter page was
colluding with the Russian huge huge and
we'll get back to that and then we have
part three which is that Muller has
something on Trump nunberg was asked by
MSNBC about that he said I think they
may and this was again part of another
one of these just very strange interview
speculation ranging from just absolute
and total panic over what he believes
may be a coming indictment from robert
muller to maybe just being drunk the
explanations have ranged from the
complex to the simple that the
insightful here is this next comment
from his MSNBC interview do you think
that they have something on the
president
I think that bad well I think that he
may have done something during the
elections but I don't know that for
things that I can't explain that unless
you were in there explaining the
atmosphere the way they asked questioned
about anything I heard after I was fired
from the campaign yes and it gets even
weirder this is what panic looks like he
spoke to CNN's Gloria Borger and just
every element of these interviews is
outrageous so if it was only those three
people they wanted they wanted
information no I'll send you the full
subpoena okay you know the molar mr.
Muller I've been warned not to go after
him I've been warned that you're wrong
that he'll he'll take you down you know
what why should I give him every
communication attack on November 1 of
2015 with my mentor Rodgers because you
might be arrested if you don't the White
House asked about it they're writing
this all off at someone who flat-out
didn't work at the White House period
same number the president's former
campaign aide is refusing a subpoena by
a grand jury and he just said on MSNBC
moments ago I think he meaning the
president may have done something during
the election but I don't know that for
sure
well I definitely think he doesn't know
that for sure because he's incorrect as
we've said many times before there was
no collusion with the Trump campaign
anything further on what his actions are
he hasn't worked at the White House so I
certainly can't speak to him or the lack
of knowledge that he clearly has the
idea that a former Trump adviser who was
interviewed by Moeller's team saying
that Carter page colluded with the
Russians and they may have something on
Trump is nothing is downright hilarious
because of how impossible it is to
believe that and what is clear here is
that whether you believe he was drunk
nervous or panicked
this is the behavior of a guy who is
extremely skittish after his own
meetings with Muller's team
he is extremely scared and apparently
rightly so based on the questions that
were asked and the requests for
documents that were made and there is
just no way that this ends well for many
many people we don't know yet who's on
the list of people that this is not
going to end well for but this is a
rattled guy I don't care how you
describe it he's scared he's very scared
it's a very bizarre demeanor and I think
that's a defense mechanism for him I
guarantee you that if Muller is going to
present you know 5-10 years of prison if
he doesn't cooperate the guy will turn
around real quick
yeah and that wouldn't be the penalty
for the contempt but certainly we
depending on what it is that Robert
Moeller knows in terms of the
investigation at large that doesn't seem
unreasonable to me it's certainly
possible five five to ten could be on
the table there I'm glad we don't have
any vacations planned for a while
because I don't want to miss a minute of
what's going on here the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad